so I need to settle a little debate what
type of pizza is better pepperoni or
cheese watch me create a presentation
using AI in 30 seconds or less I've been
using this website called Tome to help
me write scripts get Creative Concepts
for videos and just make funny mobile
meme tomes to send to my friends Pizza
presentation let's go create a
presentation pizza or pepperoni I'm
gonna hit enter and the magic starts to
happen before your eyes generating the
outline introduction ingredients taste
health benefit health benefits now let's
change a few things up I'm going to
change the color scheme here first
that's Pizza e wow all of these images
were actually generated in AI let's
change this one I'm gonna generate a few
more images and choose from those oh
this one's perfect and here's our final
tone and it is a beautiful presentation
and my favorite part is how good these
tomes look on mobile if you guys want to
check out Tome I'll put a link in my bio